welcome back to hannity well with
democrats as desperate as ever for any
signature political win joe biden and
kamal harris are becoming even bigger
and bigger liabilities for any democrat
anyone with the d next to their name
looking to keep their job in 2022
for example not only is biden's approval
still majorly underwater but republicans
are now holding a double-digit lead
among independents heading into the
midterm election cycle
because tonight the biden agenda is
failing on every single front
inflation surging our energy
independence gone the supply chain still
a mess the border still a catastrophe
dangerous crime is up in every major
city
and we're still seeing fallout from the
reckless withdrawal in afghanistan no
program covers that more than hannity
build back better thankfully dead but
that was a number one for them and kovit
is spreading across big blue states as
fast as ever so ask yourself
have you ever it's a it's an important
question to ask have you ever seen one
man
fail this much
this fast now it's all raising questions
about what do democrats do in 2024 does
anyone really believe joe biden will run
again not really no
and according to joe rogan
2024 maybe the matchup between
get this
michelle obama
and donald trump take a look
i really believe michelle obama runs
she wins yeah i think she wins she's
good she's great yeah she's intelligent
yeah she's articulate she's the wife of
the best president that we have had in
our lifetime in terms of like a
representative of yeah and telling you
articulate people that
they should win
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else